la parole est à madame frédérique
puissat rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le vice président de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues un texte sur le pouvoir
d'achat appel humilité et sens des
responsabilités
face à une inflation exceptionnel nos
concitoyens attendent des réponses
ciblées et immédiate à leurs
préoccupations du quotidien manger se
déplacer se chausser pouvoir concrétiser
leur projet et travailler plus pour ceux
qui le veulent selon leurs priorités et
les possibilités de leur employeur en
examinant ce projet de loi nous avons
veillé à suivre cette boussole étant
entendu que la protection de notre
niveau de vie relève de responsabilité
partagée l'état des collectivités
territoriales que je remercie mais
surtout les entreprises bien sûr les
ménages qui prennent aussi leur part
dans ses 106 d'augmentation
même s'il a validé la revalorisation
anticipé au 1er juillet de diverses
prestations et aides sociales le sienna
attentif à l' équilibre financier global
des mesures qu'il a adoptée a tenu à
marquer la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
la commission mixte paritaire réuni
seulement trois jours après l'adoption
de l'adoption du projet de loi par le
sénat est parvenue à établir un texte
commun à partir il faut le lire de deux
copies assez différente ce dont je me
félicite pour la partie relevant de la
commission des affaires sociales le
texte de la cmp reprend plusieurs
apports importants du sénat sans lequel
le projet de loi n'aurait pas répondu à
nos attentes tout d'abord il a inclus
l'article 1er bis que nous avons
introduit afin de limiter de manière
pérenne le surcoût associés aux heures
supplémentaires tout en recentrant ce
dispositif sur les petites et moyennes
entreprises moins de 249 salariés au
travers de ce dispositif très
complémentaire de la réduction d'impôt
qui figure dans le plfr il s'agit bien
sûr de rendre effectifs les gains de
pouvoir d'achat que les salariés
volontaires pour en tirer des heures
supplémentaires la cmp a adopté la
mesure de déblocage exceptionnelle de
l'epargne salariale
qui apportera un soutien immédiat aux
salariés dans les revenus sont
insuffisants
face à la hausse des prix elle a
également introduit l'accélération de la
procédure d'extension de l'accord
salariaux lorsque plusieurs
revalorisation du smic sont intervenus
dans les 12 derniers mois même si je
reste sceptique sur la citation des
partenaires sociaux à négocier par le
biais de la restructuration des branches
qui est l'occasion de l'évoquer dans cet
hémicycle que la cmp a réintroduit le
compromis obtenu qui renvoie les
partenaires sociaux et l'état à leurs
responsabilités respectives me semble
être équilibré
de même pour ce qui concerne la prime de
partage de la valeur une solution de
compromis a permis de revenir sur les
retenir l'essentiel de la rédaction de
l'assemblée nationale avec un dispositif
pérenne pour toutes les entreprises tout
en intégrant plusieurs rapports du sénat
en particulier la limitation du
fractionnement de la prime à un
versement par trimestre et
l'anticipation du dispositif au 1er
juillet 2022 par ailleurs la possibilité
de cumul entre l'exonération dont
bénéficie les jeunes agriculteurs et la
réduction des taux de cotisations
maladie maternité adopté par le sénat à
l'initiative de me collègue laurent
duplomb que le salut à distance a été
transformée d'un commun accord on droit
d'option pour l'un ou l'autre de ces
dispositifs
les modifications apportées par le sénat
à l'article 3 qui entend faciliter le
développement et l'intéressement de
l'intéressement ont été conservés en cmp
en particulier celles visant à limiter à
quatre mois le délai donné à
l'administration pour l'agrément d'un
accord de branche d'intéressement de
participation ou instituant un plan
d'epargne salariale la cmp a prévu que
ce délai pourrait être prorogé une fois
pour une durée maximale de deux mois
enfin je me félicite que la sublime
semences temporaire direct l'utilisation
des titres restaurant étaient conservés
dans sa rédaction issue du sénat cette
mesure ne doit pas susciter l'inquiétude
des professionnels concernés auxquels
équilibre global des aménagements
apportés au dispositif du titre
restaurant ne me semble pas porter
préjudice en sachant que j'ai
parfaitement entendu la quiétude bien
plus large de ce secteur hôtellerie
restauration restauration sur lequel
nous devons porter un regard attentif ce
texte ne puisse pas pour autant le sujet
du pouvoir d'achat nous ignorons quelle
sera l'évolution de l'inflation et
quelles nouvelles mesures seront
nécessaires en outre nous ne
méconnaissons pas la situation parfois
plus singulières des français les plus
fragiles
que ce soit dans les outre mer ou dans
les territoires ruraux les textes à
venir devront agir de manière plus
structurelle en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat des français dans l'attendu ses
prochains rendez vous je vous invite
aujourd'hui au nom de la commission
mixte paritaire a adopté ce projet de
loi et je vous remercie
merci chers collègues aient maintenant
la parole revient à monsieur daniel
grémillet également rapporteur pour le
sénat
et qui va réussir l'exploit de présenter
son rapport en 2 minutes 30
monsieur
la ministre
rapporteur jeu présidents des
commissions des affaires sociales on
aime la président de la commission des
affaires économiques mes chers collègues
donc commission a été chargée d'examiner
des trente deux articles du volet
économique du projet de loi pourvoir
d'achat si les délais d'examen du texte
de terminer par le gouvernement ont été
très critiques le compromis obtenu en
cmp est tout à fait satisfaisant je
félicite que notre commission et
imprimer sa marque de manière générale
nous avons entendu maintenir en
équilibre entre la législation d'urgence
d'une part et la liberté économique et
le droit de propriété d'autre part de
plus nous avons un souhaité combler
certains angles morts en matière de
protection des consommateurs de
régulation des marchés du christ et du
gaz ainsi que
promotion des alternatives aux énergies
fossiles c'est fondamental face à la
crise inflationniste actuelle sur le
volet énergie notre commission obtenu
deux gènes du plafond de la reine des
120 térawattheures jusqu'en 2025 et le
relèvement de son prix à 49 50
mégawatt heure de plus le cadrage
introduit sur ce volet a été maintenue
nous avons ainsi consolider les pouvoirs
de la crue à l'égard du stockage nous
avons aussi conditionnée à une menace
grave les pouvoirs de crise est prévue
la motivation de leur indemnisation de
plus nous avons associé des
collectivités à tous les dispositifs
pertinents dont l'interactivité
enfin nous avons inscrit le champ des
méthaniers flottant et compléter leurs
programmes d'investissement plusieurs
rapports sénatoriaux ont prospéré tout
d'abord les projets de biogaz
bénéficieront de solutions de
simplification en outre les
consommateurs d'électricité et de gaz
seront mieux informés autre point les
coupures d'accès seront encadrés enfin
l'impact du bouclier tarifaires sur les
collectivités sera évalué sur le volet
consommation plusieurs rapports ces
matériaux sont faces salué les nouvelles
modalités de résiliation des offres
groupées de l'assurance emprunteur à des
services de télévision et de vidéos à la
demande sont des avancées concrètes il
en va de même de la pénalisation des
manques à proportion des retards
frambourg seulement des victimes de
fraude bien sûr ces mesures techniques
ponctuels n'atténue en rien le besoin
d'une vision politique et de mesure du
raid pour autant notre commission
appelle à les adopter sans réserve je
tiens à vous remercier vous malgré ce
petit temps je tiens à remercier
l'ensemble des administrateurs du sénat
qui ont vraiment travaillé à nos côtés
et le travail qui a été fait en
conjointement aussi avec nos rapporteur
de l'assemblée nationale
bravo
exactement 2 minutes 30 merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à la
ministre madame agnès venir gâcher
ministre de la transition énergétique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs mesdames madame et monsieur
les présidents de commission mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs j'excuse ici mes
collègues olivier du soft olivier à
grégoire et olivier klein qui ont porté
également ce projet de loi et dont je me
ferai sur leur sujet le porte-voix nous
arrivons au terme de l'examen de ce
texte en faveur du pouvoir d'achat des
français après plus de trois semaines de
débats nourris je crois que nous pouvons
collectivement salué l'adoption de ce
texte qui permettrait un soutien direct
au pouvoir d'achat des français en
particulier les plus fragiles il est
adopté par le parlement dans un temps
record et aux termes d'un accord en
commission mixte paritaire
alors que nous vivons l'une des plus
graves crises énergétiques une crise où
60% de l'inflation actuelle s'explique
par l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
et que connaissent et nos concitoyens
quotidiennement je salue le parlement
d'avoir pris ses responsabilités je lui
dis ici même nous sommes dans une course
contre la montre pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements en énergie pour
l'hiver prochain avec l'adoption des
mesures du titre thoiras nous donnons à
l'état les leviers indispensables pour
agir au plus vite je voulais insister
sur quelques mesures de ce projet de loi
et saluer les évolutions apportées par
le parlement la faculté de
réquisitionner les centrales à gaz qui
produit de l'électricité en cas de forte
tension sur notre réseau le parlement
est venue limiter l'application de cette
disposition à quatre années et a précisé
ses modalités de mise en oeuvre pour la
cogénération
ces évolutions sont le fruit de
discussions avec plusieurs groupes
politiques à l'assemblée comme au sénat
le projet de terminal méthanier flottant
qui est nécessaire pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements en gaz pour l'hiver
2000 23 24 ans permettant d'assurer à
hauteur de 60% l'équivalent des
approvisionnements actuels en gaz russe
il a été conçu pour avoir le moins
d'impact possible sur le plan social et
sur le plan environnemental
c'est un projet temporaire et le
parlement est venu encadrer son
exploitation à cinq ans sur les coupures
d'énergie pour impayés le parlement a
apporté une protection supplémentaire
aux français en dehors de la période de
trêve hivernale en instaurant une
période incompressible d'au moins un
mois avant que la coupure de courant ne
soit effective cette période doit être
mise à profit pour trouver un accord
entre le consommateur et le fournisseur
enfin je salue l'adoption des mesures
visant à sécuriser le rehaussement du
plafond de la reine de vin
térawattheures nous sommes là aussi
arriver à un compromis qui permettra de
sécuriser la protection des entreprises
électro intensives et des collectivités
territoriales face aux hausses de primes
énergie en 2022 en parallèle l'état
affirme plus que jamais le caractère
stratégique d'edf avec sa participation
à l'augmentation de capital d'avril
dernier et la montée à 100% détention de
l'entreprise
ce texte répond aussi à l'urgence d'agir
directement sur le portefeuille des
français leur revenu disponible
l'ensemble de ces mesures ont été
portées par le ministre olivier du soft
nous avons avancé les revalorisations
des prestations se savent sociales
prévue au 1er janvier au 1er avril
prochain ou au 1er avril prochain
l'ensemble des prestations augmentera de
4 % cette revalorisation s'ajoutera à
celle de 1,1 pour cent perçue au 1er
janvier dernier et à celle de 1 8% perçu
au 1er avril dernier c'est le cas entre
autres des minima sociaux mais également
de la prime d'activité sur ce sujet la
volonté du gouvernement est sans
ambiguïté nous n'opposons pas la valeur
travail et le site et le soutien nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles c'est ce
que nous avons fait aussi en proposant à
l'article 3 de favoriser le recours à
l'intéressement en particulier pour les
petites et moyennes entreprises le texte
prévoit ainsi des modalités simplifiées
de mise en oeuvre et une simplification
de la valider la validation des accords
c'est ce que nous faisons enfin en
prévoyant une diminution des charges qui
pèsent sur les indépendants cette baisse
pérenne se traduira par un gain pouvant
aller jusqu'à 550 euros pour les
artisans commerçants et les professions
libérales qui gagnent l'équivalent du
smic c'était une promesse de campagne du
président de la république mais ce texte
symbolise également la co construction
dont nous avons su faire preuve ce fut
le cas par exemple à propos de la
location pour les adultes handicapés la
dea conjugale isation de cette
allocation est vrai d'un amendement
commun de bon nombre d'entre vous lors
de l'examen du texte en première lecture
et entrera en vigueur au plus tard le
1er octobre 2023 l'examen parlementaire
a également permis d'introduire la
possibilité de déblocage anticipé
l'epargne salariale jusqu'à 10000 euros
pour l'acquisition de biens ou la
fourniture de services et ce jusqu'au 31
décembre 2022 je reviendrai
particulièrement sur trois points du
titre 1 tout d'abord la pérennité de la
prime de partage de la valeur pour les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés est
conservé c'est un signal important de
visibilité long terme pour les
entreprises et les salariés qui en
bénéficient
je sais que le sujet des intérimaires a
pu amener des inquiétudes sur vauban je
tiens à assurer l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale sur le fait
qu'en application du principe à travail
à travail de valeur égale salaire égal
la rémunération du travailleur
temporaire ne peut être inférieure à
celle que par soi chez l'utilisateur
après période d'essai un salarié de même
qualification occupant le même poste de
travail en conséquence si l'entreprise
utilisatrice décide de verser la prime
de partage de la valeur à ses salariés
le travailleur temporaire en mission
dans l'entreprise utilisatrice percevra
bien également d'après celle-ci lui sera
versée par l'entreprise de travail
temporaire qui assure le versement de la
rémunération du travailleur temporaire
par ailleurs une entreprise de travail
temporaire peut également verser la
prime quant à ses salariés permanents
qu'à ses salariés mise à disposition ou
en intermission une instruction
confirmera prochainement ses modalités
d'application
par ailleurs l'article 4 qui permet
d'engager la restructuration des
branches professionnelles qui dispose de
mini mâcon lionel durablement inférieurs
au smic a été rétablie sans préjuger du
dialogue social en entreprise qui reste
le pilier des négociations salariales
c'est un levier d'action supplémentaire
pour empêcher des blocages durable qui
apparaissent et cela incitera les
branches à rester très mobilisés
notamment dans une période où le smic
augmente régulièrement du fait de
l'inflation enfin les heures
supplémentaires bénéficieront d'une
nouvelle exonération forfaitaire de
cotisations sociales patronales cette
proposition pérenne s'appliquera aux
entreprises de 20 à 250 salariés
je suis satisfaite qu'un compromis est
peut être trouvé entre les deux chambres
sur ce sujet qui allie à la fois
compétitivité et pouvoir d'achat le
texte apporte également des avancées
notoires en matière de protection des
consommateurs elles ont été portées dans
le titre 2 par leur ministre olivier à
grégoire une ministre olivier klein il
permet la mise en oeuvre de boucliers
tarifaires sur les premiers postes de
dépense des français parmi lesquels les
loyers en plafonnant à 3 5 %
l'augmentation des loyers alors qu'elle
aurait pu atteindre près de 6% et en
revalorisant de 3 5 % des aides
personnalisées au logement pour protéger
nos concitoyens qui en ont le plus
besoin le gouvernement se félicite de la
mesure qui a été adopté au sénat et
suite à l'alerté à la mobilisation des
députés sur le plafonnement de l' indice
des loyers commerciaux
grâce à ce travail des parlementaires en
lien avec leurs représentants des
bailleurs et des commerçants nous
plafonnerons durant un an la hausse des
loyers commerciaux des pme à 300% nous
rendons le consommateur maître de ses
choix et de ses dépenses c'est tout
l'objet du bouton résiliation mis en
place pour les abonnements du quotidien
et les contrats d'assurance et mutuelles
là encore grâce au travail des
parlementaires et notamment du
rapporteur le sénateur grignon et le
sénateur lemoine knees élargissons le
périmètre de ces dispositifs les
consommateurs pourront résilier en ligne
leur contrat dès lors que l'entreprise
dispose d'un mode de souscription en
ligne les modalités commercialisation
des assurances affinitaire comme les
garanties sur les téléphones portables
ou l'électroménager seront fortement
encadrée afin de mieux protéger les
consommateurs ainsi certains frais
d'incidents bancaires seront mieux
encadrés afin de renforcer la protection
des plus vulnérables
il s'agit d'amendements venue des deux
assemblées ont permis d'enrichir le
texte enfin il n'y aura pas de véritable
il n'aurait pas de véritable protection
du consommateur sur le renforcement des
sanctions et des moyens de contrôle et
de communication sur ce que nous
appelons communément les arnaques et au
rythme de développement de celle-ci sur
internet notamment notre responsabilité
est de mieux protéger les français je
donne un exemple le préjudice estimé des
fraudes aux comptes personnels de
formation actuellement au pénal
''environ les 27 millions d'euros ces
deux dernières années cela nous rappelle
la nécessité d'agir directement sur ces
sujets là je vous remercie
merci un analyste je rappelle que en
application de l'article 40 de son
douzième alinéa du règlement le sénat
examine ans après l'assemblée nationale
le texte élaboré par la cmp il se
prononce par un seul vote sur l'ensemble
en ne retenant que les amendements
présentés ou acceptés par le
gouvernement
en conséquence le vote sur les
amendements et cerise article est
réservée à nos passes ont donc à la
présentation des amendements du
gouvernement avant de recevoir les
explications de vote des groupes
madame la ministre pour le premier
aliment à un moment trois amendements
que je me permettrai de présenter
ensemble procède à des levées de cash
son je dirais nous tirerons les
conclusions de la cmp le premier
concerne l article 1er bis qui instaure
une déduction forfaitaire de cotisations
patronales sur les heures
supplémentaires
le deuxième concerne l'article 2 qui
autorise le cumul entre exonération
partielle de cotisation pour les jeunes
agriculteurs et réduction des
cotisations maladie maternité et enfin
le troisième concerne l'article 3 bis et
le déblocage anticipé de l'epargne
salariale
favorable aux 3
donc nous pouvons passer aux
explications de vote à raison d'un
orateur par groupe nous commençons par
madame annie le houérou pour le groupe
et se r
monsieur le président madame la ministre
un cher collègue face à l'ô à la hausse
de l'inflation une grande partie des
françaises et des français sont inquiets
de voir leur situation économique se
dégrade et les salariés les plus faibles
les premiers core v sont et seront
frappés de plein fouet ce texte dit pour
la protection du pouvoir d'achat
constituer un espoir pour eux vous
disiez vouloir revaloriser le travail
tout travail mérite salaire et constitue
le contrat social entre l'employeur et
le salarié les conquêtes sociales et le
droit se et le droit du travail sont les
garants d'une juste rémunération qui
garantit le pouvoir de vivre se loger
manger se vêtir se soigner se déplacer
se cultiver dans des conditions décentes
c'est pourquoi nous avons défendu la
revalorisation du smic en une conférence
sur l'est et une conférence sur les
salaires qui apporte une réponse stable
et durable comme nous nous en doutions
vous avez ignoré la question salariale
dans ce texte sur le pouvoir d'achat
les revalorisations voter pour les
prestations familiales les minima
sociaux la retraite de base les apl le
coin d'un 10 ces revalorisations sont
vite rattrapées par l'inflation la
collusion entre le gouvernement et la
droite sénatoriale lors de la commission
mixte paritaire ne fait aucun doute
ensemble vous mettez en oeuvre une
politique libérale
ensemble vous faites le choix de la
prime au détriment des salaires ensemble
vous engagez la déconstruction du statut
de salarié cette prime macron désormais
un ajustement appelée prime de partage
de la valeur n'est servi qu'à la
discrétion de l'employeur et par une
minorité d'entreprises seuls 10% des
salariés en ont bénéficié et le montant
moyen de cette prime n'a jamais dépassé
les 550 euros ce n'est pas en augmentant
le plafond des possibles que vous
augmentez la prime ni le nombre de
bénéficiaires c'est à l'heure cette
prime désocialisés défiscaliser va à
l'encontre du modèle social que nous
défendons s'éloigne du présent du
principe selon lequel chacun contribue
en fonction de ses moyens et bénéficier
en fonction de ses besoins pas de
cotisations pas de droits associés et
des comptes de sécurité sociale dégradée
c'est un affaiblissement de notre
protection sociale en permettant la
monétisation des rtt vous enfoncer un
coin vers le démantèlement des 35 heures
dans le contexte de crise énergétique
sans précédent la commission mixte
paritaire a acté quelques dispositions
utiles concernant la protection des
consommateurs d'énergie et
l'accélération des projets de biogaz
pour autant les mesures visant à
sécuriser l'approvisionnement
énergétique en gaz et en électricité ne
sont pas des mesures de pouvoir d'achat
et témoigne du manque d'ambition et de
visibilité de la politique énergétique
du gouvernement
enfin le relèvement du plafond de la
reine de vin térawattheures dégradera
encore la situation financière d'edf au
bénéfice de ses concurrents qui font des
super profits sans contribution à la
charge commune une grande réforme du
marché européen de l'énergie est plus
que jamais nécessaire en matière de
logement les dispositions visant à
contenir les hausses de loyer ne seront
pas assez efficace pour les usagers les
plus modestes la principale avancée de
ce texte elle ad conjugale isation de
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés qui
met fin à une injustice elle était
demandée depuis longtemps elle avait été
votée au sénat
mais mise en échec à l'assemblée
nationale que de temps perdu dans votre
obstination lors du dernier quinquennat
nous saluons donc cette mesure elle
constitue une belle victoire pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et
des associations qui se battent depuis
des années pour l'autonomie financière
des allocataires nous regrettons que nos
propositions pour valoriser le travail
est été balayée d'un revers de main et
ce en considération par le gouvernement
et la majorité sénatoriale
valorisation du travail par un smic à
1500 euros grande conférence nationale
sur les salaires revalorisation des
prestations sociales en fonction de
l'inflation
automaticité des prestations sociales
pour lutter contre le non recours ou
encore le rsa jeanne des propositions
contraires crête que nous avons
défendues pour permettre aux
travailleurs de vivre dignement de leur
travail et pour garantir une meilleure
répartition des richesses avec la
complicité de la majorité sénatoriale le
gouvernement ne propose que des mesures
de court terme qui ne suffiront pas à
répondre à l'urgence sociale dans notre
pays
pour toutes ces raisons en
responsabilité au regard des
insuffisances de ce texte le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains a
fait le choix de ne pas soutenir ce
texte qui ne répondent pas à son objet
affiché dans le titre
notre groupe s'abstiendra je vous
remercie
la parole est à présent à monsieur
xavier iacovelli pour le groupe rdp y
est également pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues la commission mixte
paritaire réunie le 1er août dernier est
parvenu à un accord sur le projet de loi
relatif aux mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat
face à l'augmentation des prix et au
risque de celle ci provoque sur le
quotidien des français le gouvernement a
fait le choix de proposer des mesures
concrètes et dont la mise en oeuvre
rapide permettra de répondre aux
préoccupations légitimes de nos
concitoyens ce texte je le disais
comporte des avancées nécessaires pour
protéger efficacement le pouvoir d'achat
des français je pense en premier lieu au
triplement de la prime de partage de la
valeur qui permet aux entreprises de
verser jusqu'à 3000 euros à leurs
salariés parents et 6000 euros pour
celles et ceux qui ont mis en place des
dispositifs d'intéressement à cet égard
le groupe r des pays se félicitent de la
conservation de son amendement adopté au
sénat visant à avancer d'un mois
l'entrée en vigueur de cet article 1er
effectivement il nous paraissait
essentiel de protéger les entreprises
qui agissent pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat de leurs entreprises puisqu'on
note qu'un certain nombre d'entre elles
ont versé cette prime dès le mois de
juillet à la suite des annonces du
gouvernement et par anticipation du vote
de la loi
cette prime pour ainsi être distribués
en plusieurs fois afin d'offrir plus de
souplesse aux entreprises dans la
gestion de leur trésorerie car nous le
savons que la conjoncture économique
n'offrent que peu de visibilité sur leur
situation financière en cours d'année je
pense notamment à la baisse des
cotisations sociales pour les
travailleurs indépendants et les
conjoints collaborateurs ainsi qu'aux
plafonnement de la hausse des loyers
commerciaux que nous portions côtés
d'autres groupes je pense à
l'utilisation assoupli des titres
restaurant jusqu'à fin 2023 qui pourront
désormais être utilisés dans les
commerces de détail et les supermarchés
il s'agit d'un assouplissement bienvenue
pour les salariés qui bénéficient de ces
titres dont l'utilisation est souvent
jugée trop restrictive
je pense évidemment aux revalorisations
anticipé des retraites du minimum
vieillesse de la hache ou de
l'allocation de solidarité aux personnes
âgées celles ci s'inscrivent dans
l'action que nous menons depuis 2010 est
en faveur du pouvoir d'achat de nos
citoyens en situation de précarité
nos aînés et en particulier des plus
fragiles d'entre eux qui doivent pouvoir
bénéficier d'une attention toute
particulière
il en va également de la réalisation du
rsa malgré une tentative hasardeuse de
la droite sénatoriale visant à
l'abaisser celle ci est bien nécessaire
comme les autres revalorisation prévue
preuve de la solidarité nationale
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens les plus
modestes et les plus éloignés de
l'emploi nous le disons avec force chers
collègues aucun français ne peut se
satisfaire de vivre avec 575 euros par
mois ce ne sont ni des feignants ni des
profiteurs et je suis heureux que la
sagesse de notre assemblée les temps
porté sur l'obsession de certains même
si nous l'avons vu encore cette nuit
cette sagesse n'est pas forcément d'une
valeur pérenne lorsqu'il s'agit de
protéger les plus modestes de nos
concitoyens c'est pourquoi toute
l'action du gouvernement et de la
majorité sénatoriale et la majorité
présidentielle pardon se concentre sur
une ambition faire en sorte que chacun
puisse trouver un emploi stable et une
protection adéquate afin de vivre
dignement je pense également au
plafonnement des hausses de loyer pour
les particuliers puis à la résiliation
facilité par voie électronique des
contrats de consommation et est la lutte
contre les pratiques commerciales
trompeuses
je pense enfin à la déconvenue alisation
de l'allocation adulte handicapé qui
traduit un engagement fort du président
de la république lors de la campagne
présidentielle cette dé conjugale
isation constitue une véritable mesure
de justice sociale attendue par nos
concitoyens qui ont subi un accident de
la vie et je voudrais souligner le
travail de compromis ayant permis de
réaliser cette avancée celle ci leur
assurera de préserver leur autonomie et
ne plus être dépendant financièrement de
leur conjoint cette mesure permettra un
gain de pouvoir d'achat pour cent
soixante mille personnes et le
dispositif transitoire prévue par le
texte assura de trouver une solution
juste pour près de 45 mille foyers qui
aurait été perdant par une des conjuguer
lisation simple nous saluons cette
avancée historique et par la même
occasion notre sénateur notre collègue
sénateur mouillé ainsi que l'ensemble de
l'action des groupes de notre hémicycle
afin d'aller dans le sens d'une société
encore plus inclusive pour conclure je
tiens au nom du groupe rdp ida salué le
travail des rapporteurs et l'esprit de
compromis qui a guidé nos débats malgré
des accords parfois profond l'accord
trouvé en commission mixte paritaire
démontre la responsabilité dans le
parlement fait preuve dans la crise que
le pays traverse et qui est subie par
nos concitoyens lorsque les enjeux sont
d'une importance cruciale pour la vie
des français nous devons être à la
hauteur et en capacité de nous
rassembler quelles que soient les
divergences partisanes qui traverse cet
hémicycle le projet de loi que nous
apprêtons à adopter est un texte de
compromis qui permettra de répondre à
l'urgence dans l'intérêt des français
car oui chers collègues
lorsqu'on vote 20 milliards d'euros en
faveur des minima sociaux cela s'appelle
des mesures de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat et je regrette que le groupe
socialiste ne le comprennent pas
aujourd'hui comme le disait justement
notre collègue le ministre jean baptiste
lemoyne que je salue dans les périodes
de crise l'inédit commandes pour toutes
ces raisons le groupe r des pays votre a
des convictions les conclusions de cette
cmp et se réjouit des avancées concrètes
et rapides pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français merci
la parole est à présent à monsieur
franck menonville pour le groupe des
indépendants
l'attention de toute l'assemblée
merci chers collègues le président
madame la ministre
madame et monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues selon l'insee le pouvoir
d'achat des français devrait reculer de
1% en 2022 plombé par une inflation
galopante qui a franchi la barre des 6%
ils doivent faire face à une hausse
croissante des prix de l'énergie faut-il
le rappeler qu'ils ont honte que le prix
de l'énergie a augmenté de 70% depuis
novembre 2000 21 le projet de loi
portant mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat prévoit de
mobiliser 20 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens
je me réjouis que ce texte très attendu
par nos concitoyens aient fait l'objet
d'un compromis en cmp je me réjouis
d'autant plus que de nombreux apports du
sénat ont été largement maintenu
respectant ainsi notre travail
parlementaire permettra de permettez moi
donc de revenir quelques instants sur
les mesures emblématiques
le projet de loi donc contribuer à tout
d'abord à renforcer notre souveraineté
énergétique
nous avons besoin de terminaux
méthaniers qui nous permettront de
traiter le gaz naturel liquéfié parce
que notre parc nucléaire il faut le dire
a trop longtemps été délaissées nous
nous apprêtons malheureusement à
relancer les centrales à charbon force
est de constater que nous sommes nous
sommes conduits à consolider notre
souveraineté énergétique dans l'urgence
nos concitoyens ont également besoin de
protection dans leurs contrats de
consommation et dans leurs rapports avec
les banques le projet de loi prévoit
ainsi plusieurs dispositions qui tendent
vers davantage de flexibilité je pense
notamment au remboursement accéléré des
pros de bancaire au remboursement
automatique des frais d'incident
multiples ou encore l'exonération d'une
partie des frais de résiliation
anticipée des contrats mobiles box
internet nous notre groupe avait
d'ailleurs porté d amendement dans ce
sens mais cela ne saurait suffire
la solution à la crise que nous
traversons réside à mon sens dans le
travail et plus particulièrement dans la
valorisation du travail alors que de
nombreux emplois sont à pourvoir et que
des difficultés de recrutement sont
persistantes nous devons nous assurer
que le travail paye dans notre pays et
c'est le vrai levier de pouvoir d'achat
des français des changements profonds
sont nécessaires en attendant je tiens à
saluer les mesures concrètes adoptées
qui auront un impact positif pour les
ménages français quatre d'entre elles me
paraissent particulièrement essentiel
pour répondre à l'urgence actuelle
premièrement la prime de partage de la
valeur dans l'idée voté au sénat d'un
fractionnement dans la limite de quatre
versements par an a été légérement
réécrite pour
un versement par trimestre
et l'avancement de la date
dernier deuxièmement la réduction
proposée des cotisations patronales sur
les heures supplémentaires dans les
entreprises de 20 à 250 salariés est un
début nous devons nous restons donné au
moins attachés à une exonération des
cotisations plus importantes concernant
les heures supplémentaires
troisièmement le projet de loi facilite
l'intéressement des ans au sein des
entreprises puisqu'il a assoupli les
conditions création dans les structures
de moins de 50 salariés le sénat a
également introduit donc le déblocage
anticipé de l'étoile salariale jusqu'au
31 décembre 2022
quatrièmement
quatrième point c'est aussi là des
conjugaisons lisation donc de lâches qui
est à mobiliser longuement le sénat
antérieurement et la revalorisation de
4% des prestations et des minima sociaux
les plus vulnérables sont ainsi
concernés car elle s'applique notamment
aux retraites de base au rsa aux
allocation de solidarité aux personnes
âgées les dépenses supplémentaires des
pour les collectivités seront compensées
enfin c'est un bon signal que d'avoir
revu le dise le dispositif de
réévaluation de la pension des
exploitants agricoles en actant
l'égibilité dans cette maison nous
considérons que la santé financière de
nos collectivités territoriales est un
gage de réussite pour chaque citoyen
jeux récents nous resterons donc très
attentifs à ce que les augmentations qui
pèsent sur nos collectivités et qui
entraverait leur capacité
d'investissement moteurs essentiels de
notre économie ne pèse pas et c'est pour
cela que les mesures portées par le
sénat dans le plfr
voter cette ce matin plus tôt
garantie à certain nombre de
mesures de sécurité mes mots de
conclusion vont vers nos rapporteur
madame la rapporteur frédéric puisaye
monsieur le rapporteur et grémine et
pour la praille la qualité de
du travail et du dialogue vous aurez
compris mes chers collègues ce texte est
une bonne nouvelle pour nos concitoyens
le groupe les indépendants votre à ce
texte mais le défi reste immense et
l'avenir incertain il nous faudra être
au rendez vous dans les prochains mois
merci la parole est à présent à monsieur
philippe rouyer pour le groupe des
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons cet
après-midi pour entériner un accord
important utile est attendu par nos
concitoyens
le texte élaboré en commission mixte
paritaire lundi et les résultats d'un
beau travail de nous deux a semblé
capable lorsqu'elles sont écoutés et
respectés
d'enrichir considérablement les projets
de l'exécutif
ni chambre d'enregistrement ni assemblée
de blocage le sénat a démontré au long
des jours derniers sa capacité à trouver
des solutions pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat de nos compatriotes dans les
domaines socio économiques énergétiques
quel message le sénat at il voulu
envoyer à nos compatriotes et au
gouvernement
nous avons tout d'abord souhaité
rappeler des vérités simples
premièrement que c'est d'abord et
surtout le travail qui permet
d'améliorer le pouvoir d'achat des
français et que tout doit être fait pour
l'encourager
ensuite que notre politique énergétique
à des applications en termes de coût de
la vie et d'économie du quotidien au vu
des enjeux celle ci ne peut se faire en
pièces détachées sur un coin de table
notre président bruno retailleau l'a dit
il nous faut un vrai débat sur le sujet
et une meilleure association du
parlement
enfin nous avons voulu soutenir les
ménages les plus modestes victime de la
crise inflationniste avec des
dispositifs ciblés et rapide à mettre en
place
le texte que nous nous apprêtons à
adopter définitivement est largement
marquée par les travaux du sénat et je
tiens à saluer ici le travail de nos
rapporteur sur et des cuisses à daniel
grémillet bruno belin et christine
lagarde demain grâce au sénat les
français pourront bénéficier d'une prime
de partage de la valeur pérenniser versé
au maximum quatre fois par an les heures
supplémentaires seront encouragés grâce
à une réduction des cotisations
grâce au sénat les salariés pourront
d'ici la fin de l'année obtenir un
déblocage anticipé de la participation
et de l'intéressement dans une limite de
dix mille euros c'est une vraie mesure
de pouvoir d'achat et d'encouragement du
travail dont nous pouvons être fiers
grâce au sénat les ménages en situation
de précarité pourront lorsqu'ils ne sont
plus en mesure de payer leurs factures
d'électricité
bénéficier d'une réduction de puissance
plutôt qu'une coupure sèche de leur
alimentation et ce tout au long de
l'année grâce à la détermination du
sénat est à la mobilisation de nombreux
groupes à l'assemblée nationale
l'allocation adultes handicapés sera
enfin des conjugue alizés mais que de
temps perdu
je me réjouis à titre personnel de cette
avancée majeure ayant porté depuis
longtemps ce combat pour plus de justice
le sénat
a également obtenu des avancées majeures
solvay energy du projet de loi qui nous
a été soumis pour occuper par notre
sécurité d'approvisionnement en
électricité et pas les évolution
désastreuse du dispositif de la reine h
nous avons obtenu une position de
compromis bien que fragile en réhaussant
le prix de vente de l'électricité
nucléaire d'edf et en gelant le plafond
de la lnh jusqu'en 2025 nous envoyons un
message très clair au gouvernement
la situation actuelle n'est plus tenable
et il faut vite une réforme
nous avons soutenu le développement des
terminaux méthaniers notamment au havre
nous avons voté l'accélération de la
stratégie nationale pour le gaz nous
avons proposé un dispositif innovant
d'économie d'énergie rémunérés et
volontaires pour les particuliers toutes
ces mesures sont utiles mais elles ne
remplaceront pas la fixation d'une
stratégie de long terme capable de
rétablir notre souveraineté énergétique
mes chers collègues comme vous le
constatez les acquis du sénat sont
nombreux et j'allais dire inédit sur un
tel texte je souhaite que le soit tout
autant sur le plfr qui portera le
financement de toutes ces mesures c'est
le voeu que je porte à ceux qui vont
participer à la commission mixte
paritaire tout à l'heure bien évidemment
le groupe ait l'air votre avec
satisfaction le texte issu de la
commission mixte paritaire
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci chers collègues aient maintenant
la parole revient à madame raymonde
poncet monge pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre madame la rapporteure chaque
collègue face à la hausse des prix qui
heurte violemment
les vies des plus modestes une réaction
urgente s'imposait depuis juillet
l'inflation culmine à 6 1% un record
depuis 1985 impactant les ménages de
façon inégale selon leur territoire de
vie selon leurs catégories sociales
ainsi on met les ménages ruraux
subissait une inflation de 5 9 % contre
4 % dans l'agglomération parisienne et
de manière constante les 10% les plus
pauvres de la population subissent une
inflation supérieure aux 10 % les plus
aisés l'ofcl prévoit une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat par unité de
consommation de près de 1% sur 2022 soit
la plus forte depuis 2013 sachant que
selon l'insee le revenu brut arbitrable
par unité de consommation n'a évolué
durant la décennie précédente que de 1
25 % en dix ans le ressenti d'un pouvoir
de vivre en berne est une réalité
objective alors même que depuis alors
même que selon la banque de france les
taux de marge des entreprises n'ont
jamais été aussi hauts depuis 1949 la
raison est simple comme le souligne
l'economic policy institude
l'augmentation des profits des
entreprises alimente celle des prix
combinée aux mouvements spéculatifs
en prévision de la baisse des
approvisionnements énergétiques
résultat les bénéfices des entreprises
explosent au point que même l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie a appelé à
taxer les 200 milliards d'euros d'
surprofits en 2022 les entreprises
énergétiques ce que vous refusez avec la
droite sénatoriale
face à cela pour les salariés ce projet
de loi ne propose que des mesures non
pérenne et qui toucheront une minorité
même si la cmp a limité la prime de
partage de la valeur à quatre versements
cela ne suffira pas à contrer son effet
substitutif des augmentations de
salaires déjà en 2013 le centre d'étude
et de l'emploi avait mis en évidence un
effet de substitution des primes
d'intéressement aux rémunérations en
rejoignant les conclusions de l'insee en
2020 sur la prime paie pas et si on peut
se réjouir de l'adoption du rapport
d'évaluation sur les effets de la sutie
de substitution on peut craindre qu'ils
ne nous apprennent peu de choses que
l'on ne sache déjà
inégalement réparties puisque l'insee
ledit seuls 17% des entreprises de moins
de dix salariés l'avait versée contre 58
% de celles de plus de 1000 salariés
plus largement distribué dans les
secteurs où les salaires sont déjà plus
haut cette prime ne permettra pas
d'aider des personnes réellement en
difficulté pour qui la hausse des
salaires s'avère la solution nécessaire
le smic à 15 cents euros doublée d'une
caisse de péréquation pour soutenir les
tpe pme comme nous l'avons proposé était
possible en taxant les surprofits des
grandes entreprises au lieu de quoi la
multiplication des primes désocialisés
défiscaliser va continuer d'accroître le
déficit public alors que l'assiette est
faisant exulter et déjà de 22,8
milliards d'euros en 2020 selon le
dernier rapport d'évaluation des
politiques de sécurité sociale une
situation que le sénat à graver en
élargissant les exonérations aux heures
supplémentaires
heureusement pour la sécurité sociale le
gouvernement se plie plus ou moins enfin
à la loi veil en compensant le manque à
gagner mais le même gouvernement qui se
montre ici
dispendieux au prétexte au prétexte
demain du nécessaire rééquilibrage des
comptes poussera ses réformes ce
territoire et antisociales
d'autant qu'il compte poursuivre ses
cadeaux aux plus privilégiés
faute de ressources prises sont les plus
riches ce projet de loi consiste en un
fabuleux jeu de bonneteau où les tpe
comme les ménages populaires ne sont
guère aidé pour ces ménages fragilisés
et les allocataires
ça peut les concernent hormis la vence
sur la revalorisation des minima sociaux
revalorisation sauvé de justesse contre
la droite sénatoriale
qui pour détourner le regard de
l'explosion des inégalités sociales et
des profiteurs de crise s'attaquent
régulièrement au plus exclue de cette
société de plus en plus inégalitaire
saluant toutefois la dea conjugale
institutions de la hache obtenu au
forceps après des années de luttes
militantes et parlementaires manquant sa
cible de protéger les plus vulnérables
et n'engageons pas le nécessaire
rattrapage du retard en termes de
transition énergétique retard qui
conduit aujourd'hui de fait à des reculs
le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoires votre vote
aura contre ce projet de loi je vous
remercie
la parole est maintenant à madame cathy
apourceau poly pour le groupe crc eux
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues sans surprise les
députés de la majorité gouvernementale
et les sénateurs de la majorité
sénatoriale ont réussi à se mettre
d'accord en commission mixte paritaire
sur le projet de loi pour la protection
du pouvoir d'achat nos avions assisté au
sénat à l'annoncé des fiançailles entre
la droite de gouvernement nous pouvons
maintenant féliciter les heureux mariés
qui se sont dit oui
le panier de la mariée pourtant amer a
dans sa version initiale le texte du
gouvernement prévoyait des mesures pour
protéger le pouvoir les pouvoirs d'achat
qui était largement insuffisante
ainsi le bouclier social du gouvernement
prévoit la revalorisation des
prestations sociales et du point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires à 4% la
revalorisation des retraites de base de
1,1 pour cent alors que l'inflation est
de 6% en réalité ce ne sont que des
mesures de rattrapage partiel de la
perte de pouvoir d'achat des françaises
et des français le gouvernement préfère
faciliter le versement de primes
temporaires dans les entreprises plutôt
que d'inciter les patrons à augmenter
les salaires
avec ses primes le gouvernement donne
aux salariés d'une main ce qu'ils leur
ce qui leur prend de l'autre sur le
montant des pensions de retraites au
sénat la droite a changé la donne avec
des nouveaux reculs sociaux en ajoutant
à la liste des mous des mesures de
pouvoir d'achat la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires et la suppression
des cotisations sociales des employeurs
sur les heures supplémentaires
le texte a été aggravée pour résumer
avec le gouvernement nos concitoyens ne
perdrons que 2% de pouvoir d'achat en
2022 avec la droite sénatoriale ils
devront travailler davantage pour gagner
autant qu'en 2021 les efforts sont
toujours demandés aux salariés par
contre les entreprises et les plus
riches qui ont profité de la crise ne
paieront
pas un euro supplémentaire
les efforts de la droite et du
gouvernement pour refuser la taxation
des supers profits sont particulièrement
éloquents la droite et le gouvernement
refuse de mettre à contribution les plus
riches et prive la sécurité sociale et
l'état de millions d'euros de recettes
ces pertes de recettes auront des
conséquences dans nos territoires alors
que nous subissons déjà des fermetures
de trésorerie des impôts d accueil de
caf des commissariats de police et des
brigades de gendarmerie nationale vous
allez encore aggraver cette situation
le désengagement de l'état sur les
collectivités territoriales
ça suffit à un moment donné il faut dire
stop aux politiques d'austérité et aux
logiques libérales mortifère pour notre
part nous pensons qu'une autre politique
est possible
face à l'inflation et aux spéculations
des marchés nous proposons de bloquer
temporairement les prix et pour ne pas
pénaliser nos agriculteurs d'appliquer
un coefficient multiplicateur sur
l'ensemble des produits alimentaires
pour tenir compte du prix de vente
des produits agricoles
comme nous l'avons défendue du rond
durant les débats nous proposons la
revalorisation du smic à 1500 euros la
revalorisation de 10% du point d'indicé
des fonctionnaires et la convocation
d'une conférence générale sur les
salaires par entreprise et par branche
collective pour augmenter les salaires
et donner du pouvoir d'achat
immédiatement aux travailleurs âgés bien
compris que ça ne vous faisait pas
plaisir pour les retraités nous
proposons d'indexer les pensions sur
l'évolution du salaire moyen de
supprimer la hausse de la csg 2018 et de
revaloriser le montant de l'allocation
de solidarité aux personnes âgées à 1041
neuro pour les jeunes notre grand oublié
du gouvernement nous proposons la
création d'une garantie autonomie pour
les 18-25 ans 2006 2 euros enfin pour
les collectivités nous demandons la mise
en place d'un bouclier énergie pour
compenser la hausse de leurs dépenses et
la compensation de la revalorisation du
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires
territoriaux
ces mesures sont possibles dès lors que
l'on accepte de taxer les super profits
des entreprises pétrolières et gazières
que l'on établit l'impôt sur la fortune
ou que l'on établit les cotisations dues
cice qui ampute le budget de l'état de
20 milliards d'euros par an voilà les
propositions en conclusion le
gouvernement et la droite ont profité
d'un texte sur le pouvoir d'achat pour
remettre en cause des droits sociaux et
refusait de mettre à contribution les
plus riches en tapant toujours
évidemment sur nos concitoyens les plus
fragilisés pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe communiste républicain
républicains citoyens écologistes vent
fera contre ce texte
la parole est maintenant à madame
élisabeth doineau pour le groupe union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
est arrivé à s'écouter
président madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
chers collègues alors mes propos vont
sans doute être beaucoup plus fade que
sais tu vas collègues cathy apourceau
poly mais en réalité je crois que chacun
ait est aussi dans sa ligne de nage et
donc voilà chacun s'écoute nous
examinons ce soir les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire portant sur
le projet de loi qui sont sur les
mesures d'urgence pour la protection du
pouvoir d'achat
ecoutez-la lui tous les orateurs
concernant cet enjeu majeur pour les
français je salue le compromis qui a été
obtenu entre nos deux chambres et bien
sûr avec le gouvernement je remercie
tout particulièrement aux rapporteurs et
la rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales frédéric pis en
particulier avec qui j'ai l'habitude de
travailler et dont je salue le travail
fructueux qui permettent cette
conclusion l'enjeu était important
puisque nous connaissons actuellement la
plus forte inflation depuis 1985 si nous
pouvons nous réjouir de la réaction
rapide du gouvernement
nous devons toutefois souligné que peu
de mesures du projet de loi auront un
impact direct sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français mais ne nous trompons pas
l'objectif de ce texte était clairement
exposé dans son intitulé puisqu'il
visait à protéger et non à améliorer
certains pourront le regretter mais
personne ne pourra dire que rien n'a été
fait s'est singulièrement l'article 5 du
projet de loi qui aura un effet direct
puisqu'il prévoit une réévaluation de 4%
de l'ensemble des prestations
allocations ou aides individuelles
revalorisé annuellement
le coût estimé de cette opération est de
l'ordre de 4,6 milliards d'euros pour la
sécurité sociale
je tiens à le préciser est de 2
milliards d'euros pour l'état les
collectivités territoriales en 2022 et
2023 le travail de la commission mixte
paritaire sur l'article 1er est à saluer
nous sommes revenus à la version de
l'assemblée certes tout en la complétant
avec des apports du sénat telles que la
limitation à quatre versement de la
prime ou l'avancement du versement 1er
juillet 2022 il triple les plafonds de
la prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir
d'achat ouvre la possibilité de verser
la prime aux employés rémunérés au delà
de trois smic et ray et pérennise le
dispositif
en effet la prime de partage de la
valeur ne doit ni se substituer à
l'intéressement ni ce site situé à une
part de salaire et nous y serons
vigilants
l'article 1er bis introduit au sénat
également été conservée tout en limitant
sa portée aux entreprises ayant entre 20
et 250 salariés
les articles 2 3 et 3 bis n'appelle pas
d'observations particulières concernant
l'article 4 un désaccord exister entre
notre rapporteur et le gouvernement nous
attendions en première lecture les
explications de chacun pour nous
positionner et nous avons finalement
suivi l'avis de notre commission la cmp
a réintroduit l'article 4 nous en
prenons acte
l'article 4 bis que nous avons introduit
a été conservée il ouvre la voie à une
procédure accélérée d'extension des
accords salariaux c'est une très bonne
chose bien que nous l'ayons adopté
conforme je voudrais dire un autre
grande satisfaction de la dea conjugale
isation à venir de là à achat cette
lutte de longue date et je regarde
philippe mouillé parce que je sais qu'il
a participé à cette lutte où se trouve
finalement une issue très favorable nous
pouvons nous en réjouir pour les
intéressés en tout premier lieu mais je
salue aussi la détermination des
associations qui se sont mobilisées
depuis fort longtemps ainsi que les
parlementaires qui ont relayé ses
attentes concernant le champ des
affaires économiques et du développement
durable la philosophie du texte est de
protéger les français notamment en nous
préparant à l'hiver afin de limiter la
hausse des prix de l'énergie ou encore
en nous permettant de nous défaire de
contrats aussi facilement que nous
pouvons les souscrire en premier lieu
nous pouvons nous féliciter du
plafonnement de droit commun des loyers
des particuliers de la modulation à 2,5
pour cent pour les collectivités
ultramarines et à 1 5% pour la
collectivité de corse en revanche nous
regrettons à l'union centriste que
l'amendement porté par notre groupe
visant à moduler le taux à 1,5 pour cent
pour les dix sept mille communes placées
en zones de revitalisation rurale et
bien n'ait pas été retenue ceci
constitue un enjeu décisif pour
permettre d'empêcher une explosion du
coût de la vie en ruralité il serait bon
que le gouvernement explore avec nous
des dispositions pour traiter ce sujet
d'importance
concernant le plafonnement des loyers
commerciaux à 3 5% issue d'un amendement
déposé par le groupe air des pays nous
partageons l'objectif avec une real
rédaction différentes mais nous saluons
l'adoption
concernant la souveraineté énergétique
les mesures adoptées vont dans le bon
sens au regard de l'urgence qui est la
nôtre mais la question de l'indépendance
restent ouvertes et nous devons la
traiter rapidement en conclusion nous
voterons les dispositions issues de
cette cmp tout en regrettant le délai
d'examen réduit qui nous a été imparti
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues aient maintenant
la parole est à la présidente nathalie
delattre pour le rdr
merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame et monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues est la suite de ce
marathon législatif estivale je ne peux
que me réjouir à mon tour de l'accord
trouvé lundi soir en commission mixte
paritaire sur ce projet de loi portant
mesures d'urgence pour la protection du
pouvoir d'achat comme toujours les
débats au sénat ont été riches et de
bonne tenue malgré les délais de
transmission très trop court madame la
ministre le groupe rdse apporter sa
pierre à l'édifice avec l'adoption de
mon amendement prévoyant de limiter à 3
5% la variation de l'indicé des loyers
commerciaux lit elle sait aussi je me
félicite de son maintien dans le texte
issu de la cmp je salue par ailleurs des
mesures comme la revalorisation anticipé
2 4% sur les prestations sociales ainsi
que les nombreuses possibilités créé
pour l'attribution de la prime pour le
pouvoir d'achat désormais appelée prime
pour le partage de la valeur le vote
conforme sur la d conjugale isation de
là à ce que nous soutenions de plus
longtemps dans notre groupe ou encore le
déblocage de l'epargne salariale
un compromis a été trouvé à l'article 2
pour permettre aux jeunes agriculteurs
et vous savez que cette filière mais
cher d'exercer un droit d'option entre
réductions de cotisations maladie
maternité et exonérations partielles
cela contribuera à leur donner plus de
souplesse dans la protection de la
pouvoir d'achat qui souffre tant de
crises qui se succèdent sans fin ce
projet de loi prévoit aussi d'encourager
la diffusion de l'intéressement dans les
pme je salue l'aboutissement de cette
idée déjà défendue par mon groupe lors
de la loi pacte en 2019 en particulier
par mon ancien collègue le président
jean marc gabouty la cmp a retenu une
position d'équilibré sur la
réutilisation des huiles alimentaires
usagées ce type de produit n'apparaît
pas souhaitable en l'état comme
substitut aux huiles de moteur je salue
en outre les dispositions renforçant la
protection des consommateurs face aux
pratiques commerciales abusives et aux
coûts fixes entraîné par la souscription
de certains contrats d'abonnement avec
engagement elles s'inscrivent dans la
continuité des initiatives
parlementaires de ces dernières années
concernant la lutte contre le démarchage
abusif enfin le projet de loi portant
mesures d'urgence pour le pouvoir
d'achat contient tout un volet de
mesures relatives à la protection de
notre souveraineté énergétique sur le
détail desquels le temps qu'ils mettent
à partie dans cette discussion ne me
permet pas de revenir retenons que la
france et les français seront mieux
armés pour affronter les tensions sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique en
particulier l'hiver prochain
même si ces mesures prises dans
l'urgence ne saurait nous dispenser
d'une politique énergétique de long
terme soucieuse à la fois de garantir
des prix raisonnables aux usagers et un
approvisionnement sûr et plus en phase
avec les objectifs de lutte contre le
changement climatique
quelques regrets malgré tout mes
propositions visant à faire bénéficier
la paix vpv les stagiaires ou encore à
la majoré pour les personnes en
insertion je pense aussi à mon
amendement pour un meilleur fléchage de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
notamment vers les coopératives
scolaires malheureusement déclaré
irrecevable comme de nombreuses autres
amendements venant de tous les groupes
plusieurs d'entre nous souhaiter
également une augmentation du salaire
net des plus précaires qui travaillent
cependant malgré ces réserves les
membres du groupe rds voteront pour
l'adoption des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire
je vous remercie
nous avons donc eu l'ensemble des
explications de vote et conformément
toujours à l'alinéa 2 de l'article 42 du
règlement je vais mettre aux voix mais
ce sera un scrutin public
l'ensemble du projet de loi dans la
rédaction résultant du texte élaboré par
la commission mixte paritaire et
modifiée par les amendements du
gouvernement par un seul vote j'ai donc
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe l'est républicain
sur l'ensemble du texte
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions de l'article 56 du
règlement et le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
ensemble du texte voici le résultat du
scrutin puis le scrutin 152 donc sur
l'ensemble du texte continue de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au groupe
politique est notifié la présidence nous
avons un nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 272 pour l'adoption
de 145 et contre 27 le sénat a donc
adopté
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance
prochaine séance jeudi 4 août à 17h pour
l'examen sous réserve de leur dépôt des
conclusions de la cmp sur le projet de
loi de finances rectificative pour 2022
la séance est levée